we wanted to test the leftist claim that  the gender binary is a western construct  if the man-woman distinction is a  western social construct then surely the  messiah tribe will have an entirely  different way of thinking about gender  can a man  become a woman no no it will look like  to if you want to become a lady but your  man  you have something wrong  something wrong in your family something  wrong in you for a man he has a penis  for a woman he has a vagina  what if it's a woman with a penis  but  the transphobia there is just shocking  it is gender ideology not the gender  binary which is a western  construct  they get kicked off youtube for talking  like that if they had youtube or the  internet or electricity but they have  none of those things they exist outside  the modern western bubble completely and  it's a very different world out there as  we discover